throughout the majority of 50 shades
darker I stared at the movie screen like
William Shatner in his episode of The
Twilight Zone
[Music]
just constant utter shock and awe so
let's start talking about this film
that's being released in theatres this
weekend the first 50 shades of grey was
one of the worst movies I had ever seen
in my entire life and it just so
happened to be my least favorite movie
of that year this film continues the
tradition by having Anastasia Steele
played by Dakota Johnson a perfectly
fine actress and Christian Grey played
by Jamie Dornan a man who's shown
himself to be an exceptional actor and
other things like the TV show of the
fall these are both very talented people
and here we have a director that is also
extremely talented James Foley made this
film this is a guy who directed the
excellent Glengarry Glen Ross so I
actually went into this movie with the
slightest ounce of hope and I left
pretty disappointed because the Zack
sale is the first another big shitty
fucking piece of shit the plot of fifty
shades darker is essentially that
Anastasia Steele decides hey I'll take
back Christian Grey despite the fact
that he spanked me real hard last time I
think I'm going to take him back because
I just can't get enough of that
Christian gray man do I want his body
but don't spank me again that was bad
you really really went overboard with
those five slaps last time I got to say
I don't want any more of that that's too
much for me and this time around she's
like hey I really like having sex with
you let's have sex a lot and preferably
mr.director could you please film it and
make it like an entry level softcore
porn for girls that would be the best
way to approach this and please music
editor include some current pop song
while they're having sex because of its
silence it'll be too sexual and we'll
get an nc-17 that's how these films are
made oh did I mention the author who
wrote the books wrote a Twilight fan
fiction and adapted it into her own
story and they're extremely successful
there's really no movie here it's just
more of them looking at each other from
across the room and they give each other
that I want to fuck you eyes and then
they go have sex there's nothing else
there's a small subplot involving one of
his former submissives who shows up
every once in a while looking real
ragged and I mean he doesn't like being
touched on the nipples there's actually
a scene where he takes lipstick and he
goes these are my boundaries he's like
he can't touch me here this rectangle I
can't touch me there everywhere else is
fine here's how I view this movie it's
hard to go into this film and expect
anything else than a softcore porn for
women if I go into it and expect
something oscar-worthy or amazing that
would be really stupid of me so I can't
really tell you that I'm surprised by
the fact that I thought this movie was
awful and you could use that as a
defense for the movie and say well it
has its place it's a guilty pleasure
people can enjoy it and you could defend
the movie in that way but this is the
way I view it it's the same way I view a
kid's movie a lot of people say oh well
it's a kid's movie it's okay to be dumb
it's okay to have a lot of poop jokes
it's okay to not try as hard because
it's just for five year-olds that's
bullshit I think children's films should
try just as hard as adult films and I
think that 50 shades of grey or 50
shades darker in this case should
actually at least try to make the film
even remotely romantic or you know what
at best even remotely sexy because
that's one of the things I hate about
both of these movies I said to this
movie not even remotely excited that I
was watching two very attractive people
having sex because the sex scenes are
incredibly boring
they're like softcore porn music videos
like something you'd find on the oxygen
channel at 2:00 a.m. it's like that it's
just like a bunch of like really slow
music and slow motion all that being
said the characters in this movie are
fucking atrocious all the men in the
movie are just fawning after Anastasia
Steele and she of course just once
Christian but she wants to be ordered
around all the time she lets him just
push her around into every fucking
situation she's like hey I'm going to
New York it's a work trip and he just
goes absolutely not the answer's no when
she's like and we'll talk about it later
I'm like um what is he your father like
I get that that's like how he gets off
but it's just it's so fucking annoying
it's such a horrible damaging terrible
relationship and I can't stand people
like watching these I mean in regards to
how controlling he is there's a scene
where he tells her to do something and
she's like no I'm not doing it and he
slips her and goes for once can you just
do what you're told and then she just
does it instantly and I'm like first off
that was a little much you're kind of a
dick second she does do what he says in
every scene of this movie every single
thing he asks her to do she does it
without fail where deadlines even come
from my god I hate these characters even
the attempts at making the film sexy
fail because they don't make sense in
regards to the film like for instance
there's a sequence where he takes these
two silver balls and puts them inside
Anastasia you know great that's
wonderful and she has to wear him all
night at this party and she's like what
do they do and he's like yeah see and
she's like oh okay so they go to a party
and keep in mind they have to drive to
this party she's sitting down in a car
then they go to the party and as soon as
she sits down on a chair she's like and
it just goes now you know what they do
and she's like oh I know what they do
now when you sit down oh it feels good
she was just sitting down in a car for
like 20 minutes so what they just didn't
work then the movie even has a hilarious
excuse for heightening the tension
towards the end involving this
helicopter sequence that came out of
nowhere it was so funny I was like what
it's another softcore porn movie that's
an excuse for a bunch of girls to get
together and go yes Michael would make
us six and he kind of likes to be
dominant oh my god honestly the thing I
hate the most about these movies I think
I figured it out it's that they sell
themselves as these hardcore like 18
plus super dirty movies that are like
really really graphic but they're not
really I mean there's no graphicness I
mean if they were n c---seventeen I
might at least be like okay you went for
it but no they really want to make money
so they're never going to go for it
really and the films themselves
really aren't that sexy either even
though we have two really attractive
people the stuff that they do is just
bland and boring in the way they're shot
than the music and everything it just it
sucks okay it's another terrible film
it's exactly like the first one in
almost every fucking way look if you
like these books and you like the first
movie just go see it you're gonna like
it you don't care what critics say just
go watch it you'll like it just you know
just go see it for everyone else
I'm going to get fifty shades darker a
big fat fucking ass oh my god i sat
through another one I did it thank you
so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck menage
[Applause]
[Music]
you